(upbeat)
- [Narrator] This is the collared aracari,
a toucan native to the
tropical rainforests
in Central and South America.
Their bodies are a
gorgeous rainbow of colors
with bright plumage and
large colorful bills.
Their bills are the most distinct feature.
The upper part has a saw tooth pattern,
helping them reach food on
branches they can't land on.
Collared aracaris reach
just over a foot long
and weigh up to 10 ounces.
Most of that size comes from their bills,
they take up over a
quarter of its entire body.
They mainly eat fruit,
but occasionally feed on small insects.
While they are found in
abundance throughout their range,
their population has been decreasing
due to a combination of deforestation
and hunting for the pet trade.
This is the collared aracari.